このヴィパッサナー瞑想法のこの法を観察するところで
あの で テキストのあの二十四ついてるところです
うーん あの できるだけこのパーリ語のテキストを見てください
この日本語のテキストを見て
それで私の話を聞いて
で 全くわからなくなる可能性あります
頭に日本語で叩き込む前に
この直接パーリ語でする説明をまず聞いてから
で まあ日本語の方に心を持っていってれば
まあいくらか確定する可能性あります
プナチェ・パラン・ビッキャヴェ
ビッキャヴェ・ダンメー・スダンマヌ・パッシー・ヴィヒャラティ・チャトゥス・アリーヤ・サッチェースー
カタン・チェパナ・ビッキャヴェ・ビッキャヴェ・ダンメー・スダンマ・ヌ・パッシー・ヴィヒャラティ・チャトゥス・アリーヤ・サッチェースー
イダ・ビッキャヴェ・ビッキャヴェ・イダン・ドゥッカンティ・ヤター・ブータン・パジャナーティ
アヤン・ドゥッカ・サムダ・ヨーティ・ヤター・ブータン・パジャナーティ
アヤン・ドゥッカ・ニロダガ・ニロドホーティ・ヤター・ブータン・パジャナーティ
アヤン・ドゥッカ・ニロダ・ガーミニ・パティパダーティ・ヤター・ブータン・パジャナーティ
というところで プナチェ・パラン・ビッキャヴェっていうのは
まあ比丘頼 まあ次にということで
あるいはまたということですね
プナチェ プナというのはまた
パランというのは後という
後という まあそれから
あるいはまあ次にという意味で
ビッキャヴェ・ダンメー・スダンマ・ヌ・パッシー・ヴィヒャラティ
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想する人が
まあどんどん瞑想進んでいきますから
あの まあずっと膨らみ縮みとかいろんなことを見ているでしょ
それをもう思い存分見ていたところで
まあそこら辺の方向にまあ自動的に心がまあ行ってしまうんですね
この法を 法の観察に で
いろいろ法の観察をしていたところで
まあ次にこの これも見るんだと
チャトゥス・アリーヤ・サッチェースー
四つのアリーヤというのは聖なるサッチャ
真理 この四つの聖なる真理の観察もしますと
だからこの聖なる真理という
この四聖諦ですね この四聖諦は自分の体の中で観察しなくちゃいけないんです
自分の瞑想しているんだからね
で その中で観察しなくちゃいけないんですね
四つの真理のイダ・ビッキャヴェ・ビッキャヴェ・イダン・ドゥッカンティ・ヤター・ブータン・パジャナーティ
一番目 イダン これはドゥッカン
ドゥッカであると 苦しみであると
ヤター・ブータン 如実に
ありのままに パジャナーティ
知る まあこの場合は別に確認するとかね
まあそう言ってくれれば
まあ一応それはもうまあ確認しなくてもいいんだけど
一応まあこれはドゥッカである
これは苦しみであると知る
アヤン・ドゥッカ・サムダ・ヨーと
アヤン これはドゥッカ・サムダ・ヨー
ドゥッカの現れ 生じる方法
あ これでこの苦しみがこのように生まれてくるんだとまた知る
これは苦集諦ですね ヤター・ブータン・パジャナーティ
如実に ありのままに知る
三番目 アヤン・ドゥッカ・ニロドホ
あ これはこのドゥッカのニロダ
滅であると こういうことで
あ こういう風にドゥッカが消えるんだと
如実に 如実に知るようになります
アヤン・ドゥッカ・ニロダ・ガーミニ・パティパダー
アヤン これはドゥッカ・ニロダ
苦しみの滅の ガーミニ
まあ滅に至るパティパダー
道であると これはドゥッカの滅に
まあ苦しみの苦の滅に至る道であると知る
ヤター・ブータン・パジャナーティ
ヤター・ブータンというのは
一般の日本語でもよく言ってる
このありのままっていうことですね
それは日本訳する場合は如実にするっていう風に言ってるんですね
そこでこの如実にするということは
どのように見られればいいんですかね
どんな時ヴィパッサナー瞑想で我々は空住滅道を見ればいいんでしょうかね
それはもう強引に見てもあまり意味がないんですよ
ですから このかなりの時間をかけて瞑想し続けていくと
ものすごい自然にその方向へ心が心が発見するんですよ
そういう 4つの真理を
どうしても発見しないというならば
ほんの少々心はこの方向へ
ブッダの教えに基づいてその方向へ入れておけばいいんです
この如実に見るということを知るということは
どういうふうにすれば如実になりますかね
うん  知るということもわかるということも両方おなじみなんですけど
ありのままにわかりましたと
ありのままにわかったっていうことは
この何も考えないでわかったっていうことなんです
もし考えた末で考えた結果としてわかったら
それは如実じゃないんです
ただ 思想を働かせて働かせて
ああ そうではないかという
思想自体が論理的合理的だったらそれなりの答かもしれませんだけど
それは単なるこの思想を回転したところの結果であって
如実にしたことではないんです
それから人間の考え方っていうのは
論理的かどうかっていうのは
これまたすごい問題であって
論理的に考えるんだったら
世の中の人間っていうのはみんな科学者で
哲学者ってすごいもんなんですよ
もう何でもすぐ発見できるはずなんですよ
なぜならば 世の中の科学的な事実
真理っていうのは全部論理的なものだから
合理的なものだから でも合理的に考えられないでしょうに
我々はほんのちょっとでも何か勉強して仕事をしたければ
大変勉強しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
学校 いろんな学校に入ったり
専門学校に入ったり いろんな訓練場に行って訓練したり
なかなか苦労するでしょうに
たった単純なことで仕事にしようと思ったっても
結構修行しなくちゃいけないんでしょうし
だから何十年も二旬年も三十年間も
いろんな分野でみんな研究して
やっと一人前の人になってしまうでしょう
だからそれで我々は科学者であると
プロであると言います
だから何かの分野でプロになるためにはかなり時間かかる
ということは そういう人がその分野で論理的に合理的に物事を知っているんです
例えば機械工学のエンジニアがいる
とする その工学のエンジニアが自分が研究した分野のエンジニアなんですね
工学のエンジニアだからといって一切の工学を知っているわけじゃないんです
ある一つのものだけ 例えば電子工学
あるいは普通の何とかメカニズムとか
何とかとかの工学 何か分野一つ決めるでしょう
決めてそこで研究して研究して
やっと一人前のエンジニアになるということは
その小さな項目 分野において
その人には合理的な論理的な知識があるということ
だから そのものについてその人に聞いたら
こういう問題あるんだけどと
こういうことでこうこうなってるんだと
例えば医学がありますね
みんなお世話になってるんだから
それで一人前の立派な医者になるということは大変なことで
みんな一般的なただの医者で
本当にすごい医者になるためには
もうかなり医者になってからもうかなり研究しなくちゃいけないでしょう
そこで高い高い位の学位を取ったりして
まあ教授クラスの医者になったりする
その場合は分野が決まってるんです
心臓か神経か もう何かも食道の方か
脳細胞の方とか まあどちらかとか
何か分野決まってるんですね
皮膚とかね で 我々は例えば先生
ちょっとお腹が痛いんだけどとかね
何か言ったら まあこういうこういうことで
お腹も痛いし もうこういう時はこのように痛いんですよと何とか言ったら
その専門家の人があなたにはおそらくこういうこういう病気ではないかという
それはちゃんと合理的に論理的に言う答えなんです
だからその医者にはその分野において論理的能力はあるんです
まあすばりと答えて病気治してくれたんだから
今度は夫婦喧嘩したらまた同じお医者さんに聞いてみようと言ったら
それはダメでしょ できない
あるいは自分の家で車は突然エンストになったとする
この間お腹が痛い時は
あのお医者さんがね すぐ薬一つだけで治してくれたんだから
これをその先生に電話してみましょうと言ったらできますか？できません
なぜかというと この体のそのある一部の病気に対して論理的な能力あるんだけど
車故障したらその世界については知識はなしなんです
なんでそういうことを私が言いますかというと
この論理的能力 合理的に物事を考えるということは
そんな簡単な生のものじゃないんです
あれぐらい苦労しなきゃ得られないものなんです
もし我々は自分の知識に威張って
私たちは合理的な人間だとかすごく言うでしょうね
私はどれほど責められたかと
あまり気にしませんだけど
やっぱりこの それでも説法する気持ちがなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜかというと もう言ってることを理解しようとしないなんて偉そうな
もう何ですかと その態度はと
理解しようともしないで
そういう努力もしないで
我々も西洋的な現代的な知識
勉強しているんだから
そういうふうに言わなきゃ我々にはわかりませんとかね
あの態度って何ですかとというふうに思っちゃいますよ
いくらなんでも だからこの
そんな威張るもんじゃないんですよ
威張れないはずなんです
で 私もこのすごい気をつけて
この言いたいものは全部言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
1万分の1でも言ってないんです
もうさんさんと論理的に言ったらどうなることか分からないんです
ですから この論理的に能力を得るということは
もう大変な仕事であること
まず理解してほしいんです
人間には論理的に合理的に能力があるのは一部一部の世界だけ
コックさんだったら料理について論理的な能力がある
具体的に ちゃんと合理的に
それにしてもフランス的か中国の料理かまた分けているでしょうね
中国料理のプロにコックさんにフランス料理作ってくれと言ったっても
それは無理 できません
我々の論理的の合理的な能力っていうのは
そういうふうなものであると
まず理解してほしい 大変なことである
だから世の中でものすごい膨大に学問の世界
訓練の世界っていうのはすごいあるんですね
だから我々は何かを勉強しなくちゃいけないということは
ほんの少々 わずかでも論理的なものを
体で持ってないと生きていられないんです
仕事はないんです だから仏教でも勉強することは大変
在家の人々には若いうちに勉強しておけと言っているのはそういうわけなんです
若いうちに勉強しておけば
もう死ぬまで何か食い物には困りませんと
収入には困りませんと
かえってお釈迦様から見れば
何か勉強して一人前になっているならば
ちょっとこのつながりがあるんですよ
仏教とも お釈迦様の教えも
もう理解するための最初の一歩
それ出来上がっちゃうんですね
その人は何か論理的な思考パターンを持っていて
それを論理的だから正しいんですよ
その思考パターンから話し始めると
仏教の論理世界も合理世界も理解できる可能性ありますからね
ですから この私が言いたいのは
人が論理的に合理的に正しく物事を考えるならば
普通の世界では全然問題はありません
合理的に考えると いちいちまた問題あるはずがないんですよ
例えば国際的な問題にしたっても
日本のこの 例えばこの北にある北海道の方にあるあの四つの島の問題にしたっても
もしその問題についてきちんと論理的に合理的に語れるならば
それで問題は終わりなんですよ
それは論理的に合理的に物事をうまくいってないんだから
ずーっとその話はもう延々と延々とまあつなげ続けて続けていっちゃうんです
どんな問題についてともそういうことなんです
論理的じゃない いい加減なんですね
北朝鮮のミサイルの開発問題したっても
誰一人もきちんと論理的に堂々と物事を考えるってことはないんです
向こうはいろいろ情報を隠すわ
こちらは情報知らないうちに向こうはもうけなすためにいろんないい加減なことを言ってるわ
だからもうこちら側がいい加減に朝鮮批判しちゃうと
朝鮮人から見れば何言ってるんですか
全く嘘ではないかと笑い出す
それで向こう側がやってることははっきり言ってくれれば
それまたはっきり言ってくれない
西洋ではなくて 他の国々は朝鮮国の敵やとということで
それまた嘘でしょうね
別に誰も朝鮮が敵だと思ってないし
そんな手強い相手だと全然思ってないし
どうってことない国ですけど
それでアメリカは敵ですよと
もう敵を倒さなくちゃいけないんだと言って
そっちの国民に嘘をついているでしょうに
そういうどちらにも論理的じゃないんですね
こちら側もあちら側も
だからミサイル問題にしたっても
もう何の解決方法もない
だからそうやって国際政治であろうが
家庭の中のことであろうが
会社のことであろうか
工業的な世界のことであろうか
人が論理的に合理的に物事を考えるというんだったら
すばりとぴったしの答えがいつでも出てくるはずなんです
それ何も問題はなし ですから理解してほしいのは
人間にはこれは大変な仕事なんです
論理的になるということは
そんな簡単なものじゃないんです
きつい修行を要求するんです
医者になるということは
半年間でなれますか？これ何十年もかかるんですよ
ものすごいきつい修行を要求しているんです
それでも完成されてないでしょう
医学の世界で論理っていうのは
政治家になりましょう
経済学者になりましょうと思ったら
じゃあ来週 再来週 金曜日に来ると私は経済学者になってきますよと
できますか？誰にもできません
それだったら それまた年
年かかります ほんのちっぽけな論理を身につくために
なぜちっぽけかというと
ただ単に経済学で分かったんだからと生きていられませんだから
また様々な知恵が知識が必要でしょうに
その場合は人の知識を借りなくちゃいけない
ですから ほんのちっぽけな論理しか人間に身につくことはできないし
時間の問題でたくさんできないわけないんだけど
能力としてはね 経済学者もお医者さんに経済学を勉強することは別に無理じゃないんですよ
やればできますけど 問題は時間
時間がないんです 大学病院の大教授に
大教授に音楽家にもなりたいんだと
有名な演奏家になりたいと思ったら無理じゃないんですよ
できますけど 時間があるかと
そういうことだから この論理っていうのはそういうこと
そういうふうなのに この高慢さ
傲慢さ 何なのかと どんなものにすぎても
すごい知ったかぶりで喋ると
そこで人間はよく考えてるんですよ
あれは妄想なんです ただ頭が回転しているだけ
論理的じゃないんです
そういうことだから 例えば全てのものはドッカでやりますよとか
なんとかとか 頭で考えて分かったそうと言っても
それは信頼できますか？泥でも何でもないのに
そんな無理だと思いますけどね
もしこちらのどなたが
まあ病気のことだったら私に任せときなさいと言って
人の治療したり薬あげたりすると
それはまあ黙って見ていられますかね
ちゃんと免許を取っている医者でない限りは
ちゃんと免許を持って
免許を持ってる医者であろうか
こういうところでそんな診断なんかしないでしょうに
ちゃんと自分の診療所という研究施設でないとできませんだから
ですから 我々の思考っていうのは信頼できません
私はこう思ってますよとかね
そんなものは全然信頼できません
言うことは本当に私はそう思ってますよと心の中見てまた違うことなんです
ほとんど心の中で違うことを考えて違うことを喋ったりもする
それに乗せられちゃったらとんでもないことになるでしょうに
大体我々心の中の感情が別にあって
腹の中に違うことがあって
すごい合理的に違うことを喋る
それで人をそれに乗せられて
裏で自分の目的を何とかして達成しようかなとかね
そういう話なんか論理的には絶対ありえません
一番分かりやすいのは政治家の話とかね
ああいう話は決して論理的じゃないでしょ
いい加減なうわごとだけでしょうね
でも堂々と喋る どんな国でも一番偉い人々
権力的に 喋るものは単なるもう無駄話
でも人々はそれに乗せられちゃうでしょうね
そういうことだから あの
人の思考っていうのは
まあまるっきり信頼できません
だから人の話を知りたい
信頼したければ 医者が医学について喋ると
その分だけ信頼できる
心臓の外科がどのように心臓が病気になるかと
どのようにこれは病気にならないように気をつけた方がいいかを教えてくれると
その部分だけ信頼できる
空の星ばっかり見ている人がいるんだったら
その人は星について色々語ると
それその部分だけ信頼できる
それ以外は信頼できません
たとえ本人が嘘を言っているつもりではなくても
嘘にはなりませんですけど
真実にもなりません そういうことだから
ドッカについても苦しみについても
よく考えてわかりましたと言うんだったら
それはちょっと置いておいた方がいいんですね
知るということは ヤターブータンパジャーナって如実に知ることなんですね
この如実に知るということは
考えないで知ることなんです
考えることはちょっと置いておいて
考えないで知れば 知って知れ知ればね
まあそれは知ったことになるんです
そういうことだから 仏教はアタッカーワチャラン
論理合理を通っているんだと
乗り越えているんだと
関係ないんだと だから論理的に知るということは
かなり時間かかる大げさな仕事なんです
例えば仏教学もあるでしょう
世界中でも百年も研究しているんですよ
この仏教学者たちがほんの一部
一部しか研究していないんです
それに一生かかっちゃうんです
どれぐらい仏教の世界幅が広いかというと
誰かが仏教学卒業したんだからといって
仏教だったらその人に任せて
とんでもない話 その人にあなたは何を研究したんですか？と聞いてみないと
その中でも一部 例えばチベット仏教を勉強していたとしても
チベット仏教を全部勉強したわけじゃないんですよ
その中のほんの一部 ですから
仏教はもう だから学者の中でドッカをわかった人は一人いません
因果法則をわかった人は一人いません
ほんのもう巨大な 例えば富士山みたいな大きなもので
ほんの砂一つ持ってきて
まあ任せておけと富士山のことだったらで言うことと同じなんですよ
富士山知ると言ったっても
いろんな見方があるでしょうね
それはまあ美学的に見るかと
そうするともう一年中見ておいたっても
それでも終わらないでしょうね
その日でその日で風景が変わっちゃいますから
あるいは地理学的に見るか
いろんな方法があるでしょうに
あるいは火山通してみるか
あるいは普通の登山する人を通して富士山を観察するか
だから見方がたくさんありますから
全部知ったというならば
そのありとあらゆる学問のいろんな方法で見ておかないと
だから仏教学の人であっても
ちょっと富士山のちょっとひとかけら
砂一つ持ってきて あるいは石一個持ってきて任せとけということと同じなんですね
だから仏教学者の方々はものすごいたくさんいるんだけど
日本にしていたって仏教大学どれぐらいあるんですかね
仏教学大学仏教学部からどれぐらい学生毎年毎年出しているでしょうに
でも一人も仏教わかっている人はいません
ありえないんです それは
だから論理的に何か脳細胞を働かせて訓練して知るということは
ものすごい大きな大変な仕事
それで年取って死んでしまっちゃう
時間間に合わなくて そういうことだから
一切を知るためには この論理方法
合理方法っていうのはあまり役に立たないんです
だから 本当のところは
仏教では論理合理的だと言うんだけど
私もよくよく言うんだけど
それはちょっとした意味があって言うのであって
それは正しい方法ではありません
それでも知ることはできないんです
単なる論理だけで 理屈だけでは
だからお釈迦様が提示して提案しているのはヤタハブータンパッサティ
如実に知りなさいよと
それしか知る手段はない
如実にすると論理的に苦労する
あの時間はカットするんです
全部 で カットして直接知ることができます
だからこの修行はそれにも必要なんですけど
何のための修行かというと
この頭働かせてものを知る癖を一旦やめてもらわない
それやめてもらうために
この観察修行をさせているんです
論理的に考えることはやめてくださいと
この考えるたびに間違うんですよ
それでも癖で考えちゃうんです
考えて知った知ったというこれはすべて間違う
正直に考えると私もあまりこのもうあまり攻撃しませんだけど
本当に正直に知りたくて考えて何か言うと親切に何か教えてあげますけど
時々正直じゃないと 正直じゃないんですよ
自分がよく頑張ったなと褒めてもらいたく考えて喋ったりすると
もう狂暴に反論しなくちゃ
反論というか攻撃しなくちゃいけないんですね
その場合は明確に嘘だから
正直に知りたくて考えて考えて何か言うと
嘘言ってるわけじゃないんです
もう頑張ってるんだから
まあ道が間違ってるんだけど
本人が一生懸命頑張ってるんだから
その時はまあ一応一般的な反応ではな
ただ可愛いと でもやってることは別に意味がないんだけど
まあ可愛いんだと ですから
その人には親切なんですけど
他の人にはやっぱり親切にするわけにはいきません
だからこの観察修行っていうものは
この心にある この考える癖
考えた末で知りましょうという
その癖をなくすとこまで
消えるとこまでやらなくちゃいけない
それ癖消えちゃったら大体別に考えないでパッとあ
こういうことやと瞬時にわかるんです
ですから このヤタハブータンパジャナーって如実に知るということの意味は
そうやってこの修行の結果として知るわけではなくて
ただ知るだけ だから直知ということなんですね
じゃあ二五に行きます
カタマンチャビッハレ
ドゥッカアリアサッチャンジャーティピドゥッカジャラピドゥッカマラナンティドゥッカソウカパリデヴァドゥッカドーマナッスパヤーサーティドゥッカアッピエーヒ
サンプラヨーゴドゥッコピエーヒヴィップラヨーゴドゥッコヤンティッチャンメラバティタンティドゥッカサンキッテーナパンチュパーダーナッカンダー
次も入ってますね パンチュッパーダナカンターピドゥッカ
カタマンチュ カタマンチュというのは
うんと まあ「どれぐらいありますか？」と 「
どのようにどれぐらいありますか？」という疑問の言葉で
ビッケーヴェドゥッカンアリーサッチャン 「
ドゥッカという苦しみに対する聖なる真理はどんなものでしょうか」と
そこでお釈迦様はもうすごい簡単に「こういうものはドゥッカですよ」と言うんです
ジャーティピドゥッカ
ジャーティっていうのは生
生まれること ドゥッカである
ジャラーピドゥッカ ジャラーっていうのは老いること
老いることドゥッカである
マラナンピドゥッカン
死ぬことドゥッカであると
これワンセットなんですね
生まれて えっと 次に まあ年取って
まあ老いて 死ぬ それは現象についてのワンセット
生まれて年取って死ぬ
次にソーカパリデーヴァドゥッカドゥーマナッスパーヤーサーピドゥッカ
長い言葉ですけど これは短く切るんです
ソーカっていうのは まあその場合は日本訳でもいいんです
まあ悲しみなんですけど
憂いですかね  憂い 悲しみ
苦しみ  で ソーカっていうのは憂いかもしれない
パリデーヴァっていうのはもう泣くことなんですね
かなり激しいんです またドゥッカが入ります
この場合 ドゥッカっていうのは痛み
体の病気とか痛みとかね
だから前のドゥッカは違う
意味は 今出てくるドゥッカは「まあ苦しい」と我々が言ってる苦しみなんです
体の苦しみ ドゥーマナッスっていうのは悲しみですね
心の悲しみ ウパヤーサなんでしたっけ？次に
えーと こちらはチャン
誕生 老衰 死 前ですね 憂い
悲しみ 苦しみ 次にまた憂いとか
悩み  悩み まあドゥーマナスタっていうのは普通の悲しみで
ウパーヤーサっていうのはもうちょっと強くて
この引き摺っていくんですね
なんとなくいうと ため息したりとかね
うーん まあ悲しみのかなり強い方だと思った方がいいんですね
次にアッピエーヒ サンパヨゴ ドゥッコ
アッピエーヒっていうのは
まあ好きでもない人々
好きでもない物事あれ
嫌な人々 嫌な物事と合わせること
付き合うこと それもドゥッカであると
で ピエーヒ ヴィッパヨゴ
で 好きな人 好きな人々
好きな物事から離れることもまたドゥッカであると
次にヤンピッチャン ネラベティ
ヤンピッチャン 欲しがるもの何かあると
ネラベティ それは得られない
欲しがるものは得られない
欲しいものは得られないこと
それもタンピ それもドゥッカンドゥッカであると
まあそうやって現象的なことを言いながら
まあ結局諦めちゃうんですね
サンキッってのはまあ引いてみれば
引いて言えばパンチュ パーダナ カンダ ドゥッカ
この体のある全てのものはドゥッカである
五蘊全てドゥッカであると
肉体も苦しみ 感覚も苦しみ
思想も苦しみ 心も苦しみであると
だから色受想行識という 5つも結局は苦しみでしょうと
もう飽きちゃった 飽きちゃうんです
だからそれは直視しなくちゃいけない
如実に知らなくちゃいけない
考えて知ると 他の人と違う考え方を言うと
もう揺れるんですよ 心は
ある人が考えて考えて
やっぱり例えば「悲しみは苦しみですよ」と考えて決まっているところで
また他の人が来て「悲しみは苦しみじゃないんですよ」と
あれはすごくいいことだと
何も悲しむことがないと
人がバカになっちゃいますよと
ボケてしまいますよと
心はすごい刺激必要ですから
それでみんな生き生きしてるんではなくてったら
そういえば「ああそうだ」と思っちゃうでしょ
だから考えてする知識は当てにならない
違う考え方を出しちゃえば
これ壊れますからね 直視したものにはもう考え方入る余地がないんです
如実に知ったならば それからこのジャーティという生まれることを
お釈迦様はまた説明してやるんですね
だからこの経典の場合は注釈も経典の中に入ってるんです
それは実践に大変必要なものだから
項目だけ言って止まることではなくて
この一つ各項目においての注釈も同じ経典の中に一つにワンセットで入ってるんですから
ですから一番この学者の世界でも信頼できるところなんですね
カタマーチャ ビッケーウェ ジャーティ
ジャーティというのはどういうものでしょうか
ヤーテーサン テーサン サッターナン タンミ タンミ サッテニカーイエ
ジャーティ サンジャーティ オッカンティ アビニッパンティ
カンダナン パートゥバオー アヤタナーナン パティラボー アヤン グッチェティ ビッラヴェ ジャーティ
こちらではただ誕生のことを言ってるんですけどね
生まれるということを言ってますけど
ジャーティっていうのは誕生
生まれること サンジャーティっていうのは同じ言葉なんですけど
こちらは誕誕生入体と書いてますけどね
オッカンオッカンティ発生と書いてますね
アヴィニッパンティ発生かな
一応この生まれるということのこの同義語で
ジャーティっていうのは生まれるっていうこと
サンジャーティということは生まれるっていうこと
オッカンティっていうことは生まれるっていう意味なんです
アヴィニッパンティっていうのは生まれるっていう意味なんです
全部意味は生まれるっていうことなんです
で カンダナン パートゥバオー
カンダナン パートゥバオーっていうのは体が現れるっていうこと
カンダって言えば五取相ですから
体と感覚両方だから 体と感覚が現れることっていう
アヤタナーナン パティラボー
アヤタナっていうのは認識器官なんですね
眼耳鼻舌身なんですね
もし眼耳鼻舌身が現れたら
それは生まれてるっていうことなんですね
これは生まれるっていうこと
うん いかん この誕生をめでたいことじゃないんですね
仏教では それ自体は苦しみであると
生まれて大変おめでたいっていうのは
もう一般の俗世間の考え方で
だからそれは論理的ではありません
生まれた自体も不幸の表れなんです
そこでこの生まれるという方法もいろいろありますから
そこでたくさんの言葉使っていて
もう卵から生まれるやらね
それはもう体から出てくることだからね
もう体を同じ体分解して生まれることもあるし
一つの動物は二つに分解したところで二つの動物になるでしょう
それで一人一匹の苦しみが倍になるだけなんですね
この下等動物は大体分解して増えるんだからね
一匹の微生物はそれ自分一人だけで苦しみなのに
それで分解して二人になる
二匹になる 二匹になったところで
この二人が同じぐらい同じように味わなきゃいけないんですね
このカンダナンパートバゴというこの五蘊が現れるという
それはこの まあこの人間より高いところの生命には
この あの 我々みたいにこの体から生まれるということはないんだそうです
ですから 例えば天界とかね
もう天界でもお産するとか言っちゃうと
そちらにも大変病院やらね
もうお産婦さんといいんですか
あの 何です お産婦さんとかいろいろ必要になっちゃうでしょうね
それだったら何のために天国に行ったんでしょうかということになりますから
そちらの体は違いますから
自然に発生するんですね
ですから そこはもうカンダナンパートバウという言葉で
もうそちらも入るように言ってるんです
このアエトラナンバティラボというのは
もっと高い次元の梵天とかになっちゃうと体もない場合もあります
体苦しみだからその苦しみ控えて
そうするとこの認識機能だけ働くんですね
体がなくて ですから それはまあ超次元的な
あの 生まれで どこへ生まれたって生まれた人がその生を死ぬまでやらなくちゃならないんですね
次はジャラ カタマーチャ
ビッケー ジャラ  老いというは何かと
ヤーテーサンテーサンサッターナン
そのその生命に そのその生命次元において
サッタニカータは生命次元ということ
生命 まあ種類ですね 生命次元においてジャラ
老いること ジーラナッター
まあ同じ言葉なんですね
カンリッチャン パーリッチャン
ワリッタチャッター アーユノーサンハーニ
インドリヤーナンパリパーコー
アヤングッチャティビッケージャラ
で 全部同じ意味で まあ年取る
老いるという意味なんです
まあ別々に意味言うと
ジャラっていうのは一番単純な言葉で
老いるって意味 ジーラナッターっていうのは
まあボロボロになるという意味
そうするとカンリッチャンというのは
何て言いますか 壊れるという
壊れていくこと だから体の場合はあっちこっち壊れて壊れていく
パーリッチャンというのは
まあ割れ目が入ったりとかね
ヒビ割れが入ったっていうような意味で
あの この言葉はだいたいこの葉っぱとかね
年取ってくると黄色くなっていく
そういう感じで使っている言葉なんですね
ワリッタチャッター ワリッタチャッターっていうのは
この年取ると我々の皮膚なんかはもうシワですか
シワがいっぱい出てきてしぼんでいっちゃうんですね
それもう皮膚だけじゃなくて
全て筋肉も内臓も全部そうやって縮んでいっちゃうんですね
この縮んでいくこと しわが出てくる
次の言葉 アーユノーサンハーニ
アーユノーサンハーニっていうのは
アーユっていうのは寿命
生命力 サンハーニっていうのはもう壊れていく
生命力がどんどんなくなっていく
次の言葉 インドリヤーナンパリパーコー
インドリヤっていうのは器官ですね
器官はもうあの もう期限になっているということ
パリパーカっていうのは熟するという意味なんですけど
それで終わりなんですね
それも植物から取っている言葉で
木の実やらね そういう木に出てきた実だったら
どんどんどんどんどんどん一人前になるんですよ
一人前じゃなくて まあ立派な木の実になるでしょうに
なったらどうなりますか？もう落ちなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 熟するイコールもう年取るということで
だから我々の目にしたってもインドラっていうのは器官だから
器官は機能してもう終わりになってしまっちゃうんですね
もう見えなくなっていく
聞こえなくなっていくっていう風に
全部器官は鈍くなっていっちゃうんですね
そういうことはジャラーですね
老いること と まあ定義ですから
定義といったっても これあのまあ辞書
同義語辞書なんですよ
これ一応インド文化的なんですね
言葉の意味というよりも
このありったけの同義語をまとめちゃうんです
次にマラナン 死ぬということ
カタマンチャビッケマラナン
死って何かと ヤンテーサンテーサンサッターナン
そのその生命のタンマタンマーサッタニカイ
そのその次元においてチュティ
出ていくこと チャワナタ
同じ言葉 出ていくこと
その生命次元から出ていっちゃう
消えてしまうこと ベード
もう別れること 別れること
アンタラダーナン なくなること
見えないこと マッチュマラナン
死ぬこと カーラキリアっていうのはまた時間をやってしまったという意味で死ぬことなんですね
時間 時間ですよって意味なんです
終わったですよってことでしょう
カーラキリアっていうのはカーラっていうのは時間
キリアっていうのはもうなすということで
だからもう時間ですよということなんです
カンダーナンベード カンダーっていうのは体の五蘊だから
その五蘊は壊れてしまう
次にカレーブラッサミッケイポ
カレーブラっていうのは死体
死体になること ニックイッパっていうのは捨てるということで
だから生きていて死体として捨てる
それも死ぬということで
ジーリチンドヤッサウパッチェド
ジーリチンドヤっていうのは生命力のこと
生命力がなくなる それはまだなしということ
次にあるのは ソーコー
こちらの訳では えっと
憂いと  憂い とは何か それからほとんど同じ定義でいきますからね
ただ言葉変えるだけ カタモーチェ
ビッケーウェーソーコー
ヨーコービッケーウェーアンニャタランニャタレーネ
ビャサレーネサマンナーガタッス
アンニャタランニャタレーネ
ドッカダンメーナプッタッス
ソーコーソーティナソーティジャッタン
アントーソーコー アントーパリソーコー
アヤンウッチャティビッケーウェーソーコー
まあそれほど意味にならないんですけど
まあ何かこのビャサの災害
災難に遭ったところで
何かこの苦しみ 何か苦しいことに
不幸なことに出会った時
ソーコーソーティナ まあ憂いが生まれてくるでしょうと
アントーソーコー 心の中で生まれてくるこの感情
不幸に出会ったら もう何でもいいんです
次にパリデーヴォ こちらは悲しみと書いてますね
パリデーヴォっていうのは
本当はこの声出して泣くことなんです
声が出るってことなんですね
それで何かこの不幸に出会ったら
アーデーヴォ パリデーヴォ
アーデーヴァナ パリデーヴァナ
アーデーヴィタッタン
パリデーヴィタッタン
アヤンウッチャティビッケーウェーパリデーヴォ
嘆き わめくこと パリデーヴァ
それからドゥッカン カタマンチャビッケーウェードゥッカン
ドゥッカ 苦しみって何ですかと
あのドゥッカは本当に苦しみだけで訳できるのはこの場合だけ
普通はこの苦集滅道の場合は
苦っていうのは苦しみっていう意味ではないんです
この場合だけ苦しみ この場合は苦聖諦ではなくて
苦聖諦の中の一部ですからね
ヤンコービッケーウェーカーイカン・ドゥッカン
カーイカン・ドゥッカン
体の苦しみ カーイカンアサータン
体で我慢できないこと
カーエサンパスダン・ドゥッカン
体に何か触れて 殴られて
落ちて というふうに体の中に生まれてくる苦しみ
まあ我慢できないこの感覚が苦しみと言うんだと
だからそれはいつでもあるわけじゃないんです
怪我したり 落ちたり 殴られたり
もうなんとかなったら
長い間座っていたりすると足が痛いとかね
まあその痛みなんですね
まあこの苦しみというのは痛みですね
このドゥッカの意味は
痛みと訳した方がね あまりダブらないんですね
それでドゥーマナッサ
ドゥーマナッサはこの悩みということでね
一般的な意味で悩みということ
それはチェータシカン・ドゥッカン
この体の痛みと心の悩み
あるいは心の痛みでもいいんです
まあ心の痛みって言ったらちょっとわかりにくいしね
ですから 体の場合は痛み
心の場合は悩みというぐらいのことで
心に生まれるこの我慢できない
嫌な気持ち 悩みの気持ちは
[笑い]一旦定義全部は言っておいた方が
かなり長く延々といきますけど
早く説明します ウパーヤーサ
カタモーチャ・ビッケーヴェ・ウパーヤーソ
うーんと こうだっけ  レイでしょうか
悩みで言ってるんですか
うんうん  何か災害にあったところで
心の中でなんか燃えてるような感じで
火がついたような感じで
わさび食べたような感じになると
心の中で あの次にこの日本語のテキストでは二十五
また比丘たちを愛せない者たちと結ばれることは何かと
そちらでこの イダ・ヤッサ・テーホンティ・アニッッター・アカンター・アマナーパー・ルーパ・サッダー・ガンダー・ラサー・ポッターッバー・ダンマ
イエーヴァー・パナッサ・テーホンティ・アナッタ・カーマ・アヒタ・カーマ・アパーサ・カーマ・アヨーガッヘーマ・カーマ
イエーテーヒ・サッディン・サンガッティ・サマーガモ・サモーダーナン・ニッシーバホ・アヤン・ブッチティ・ビクケ・アッピーヒ・サンピヨーゴ・ドゥッコ
で イダ・ヤッサ・テーホンティ・アニッターっていうのは希望はしないもの
希望はしないもの アカンターっていうのはあまり良くないものって意味で
アマナーパーっていうのは好みでないということで
まあ好みもないし 希望もしないし
良くないもの 良くないっていうことで
どういうものかというと
ルーパ 見られるもの サッで音
それからガンで香り それから味
それから体に触れるもの
それから考えること 考えることは入れますか？入れないかな
考える対象も入れた方がいいんですね
いろいろ考え事 その見たくもない
希望もしない 自分にとっては良くないものを見えたりすると
それあまりいい気持ちじゃないんですね
で 聞こえたりすると 聞きたくもないものすごい嫌な音を聞いたりすると
味も味わいたくない味を味わったりすると
体に触れて触れてほしくないものを触れたりすると
それから考えたくないものはもう考えなくてはならなくなったりしたりすると
ジェーヴァ パナッサ テー ホンティ アナッタカーマ アヒタカーマ アパースカーマ アヨーガッヘーマ カーマ
そういうものは出てくると
自分にとってはもうものすごい苦しみが生まれてくる
だからその場合はもうどうせ逃げたくても逃げられないんです
逃げたきゃ 逃げられるんだったらすぐ逃げますから
そういうものと一緒になったということは
もう逃げられないんです
ですから一緒になってしまった
同じくなってしまった
次にカッタ モーチ ビッケー ピーヘ ビッパ ヨゴー ドゥッコ
それから好きなものから離れること
愛するものたちと結ばれないことは何かと
これ 26番目 日本語のテキストで 26番目
あまり難しくないんだから
日本語で読んでみたっても
まあそれぐらいでいいと思いますけどね
前の言葉の反対ですね
見たいものなんですけど
まあ消えてしまうと 聞きたい音なんですけど
それは消えてしまうと
味わいたいものなんですけど
もうないと で もっとさらに分かりやすくするために
こちらではね えーと 体の利益を望み
繁栄を望み 安楽を望み
安穏を望む 母あるいは父
あるいは兄弟 あるいは姉妹
あるいは友人 あるいは何でしたっけ？知己
あるいは親族たちがおり
それらとともに集合しえないこと
出会えないこと 結合しえないこと
交差点ですか？交差しえないことがあります
だから自分 大変大好きな父であろうが
母であろうが 兄弟であろうか
友人たちであろうか そういう人々となかなか交際ももう何もできなくなると
そうするとかなり苦しみが生まれてくるんですね
まあそうやってごく一般的にわかりやすいことなんですけどね
そういうものを考える必要ないでしょうに
例えば子供が死んだと苦しいと
そんなことを考える必要ないんだから
両親が死にまして 大変苦しいと
突然親戚が亡くなってしまって悲しい苦しみと
そういうことが世の中でいくらでもありますから
これまたわからないというとね
だからこのリクエスト使うんだから問題なんですよ
毎日のことでしょ 毎日のこと
人類はそういう苦しみを味わわなかった時期はなかったし
誰にでも母と別れる 父と別れる
子供と別れるとか もういくら何でもそういう経験があるのに
また変ところなことを考えて
だから考えるところおかしいんですよ
で 生きることは幸せやとかね
余計なことをいろいろ考えてる
神様が作ったり いろんなことをしたり
戦争したり まあ下らんことをやっている
単なる何のことなく まあやっぱりこれはこれが人生かと
子供が死んじゃった かなり苦しみが生まれた
これが人生 それではそれが人生でしょうに
それをるっきり変ところになことを考える
死んだやつと何か会える方法ないかとかね
宗教家に教えてくれと
だから無知もアホもっていうのはもう想像を絶するアホらしさでしょ
なぜあんなバカなことを思う？犬でもやらんほどのものすごいバカでしょうに
犬よりも動物よりも知識が働かない
それは人間の理屈の世界なんです
そういう理屈ですかね
我々が大事にしているのは
何の理屈もなしに ただ単に普通にいれば
それが人生ですという
それだけで終わる 家に行こうといったところで
家がないと火事になってるんだと
それですごくショックでしょうね
もういるところはなくなっちゃったんだから
ああ これが人生ですと
それで終わればいいんです
そうではなくて 誰かのたたりではないかとかね
何か考えたりする 千束供養しなかったんだから火事になったんではないかとかね
そこで何か救済方法 脱出する方法を探したりする
そこをもう頭の悪いところをもう呆れちゃうんですね
だから まあそうやって考えて知るっていうことはありえないんです
結局は考えて知らないことになっちゃうんですね
人間が毎日このような苦しみに出会って
一生懸命考えてるでしょ
考えて この苦しみの真理から逃げていくんですね
だから考えちゃうと間違ってる結果にいる結果を得るだけ
そこで永遠の命とかね
魂は死にませんよとかね
色んなことを言ったりする
魂があるかないか 未だに何の証拠も人から何かも何にもないのに
なんのことなくあると思ったりして
そういうのは全て考え方から出てくるものなんですね
だから一切真理知りたければ
もう一切思考は使わないことなんです
どうしても使いたければ
お釈迦様がこの延々と言ってる方向へ使った方がいいんです
あまり難しくない すぐ事実を説明して
そこで止まっちゃうんです
この場合も 父から離れるは
母から離れるは 兄弟から離れるは
本当は一緒にいたいんです
自分のことをよく可愛がってくれる
自分のことをよく心配してくれる
だから一緒にいたい でも離れると消えてしまう
死んでしまう で 悲しみが生まれる
そこはもうどうしようもないこと
ことで だからそれが人生ですと
生きるということはそういうことですと
そこでストップできないのは無知だから
ストップできる人にはすごい智慧があるんです
これが人生ですというところでストップできれば智慧があるんです
何も判断もそれ以上なし
希望もなし 希望と欲望だから
希望があって 判断があって
評価があって 延々と思考を働かすと
まるっきり違う方向へ行ってしまっちゃうんです
次に何番目でしたっけ？ 二十七番目
簡単だから日本語だけでも察していきましょう
また比丘たちよ 求めて得られない苦とは何か
比丘たちよ 生まれる法のものである
生まれる法とか何とか言ったね
何ですかね そのダンマですから
生まれる性質 生まれる法則ですね
生まれる法則のものである有情に次のような欲求が生じます
我々が生まれる法則のものでなければ良いのに
こんな風に生まれなかった
生まれなかったならばいいんじゃないかなという希望なんですね
生まれてこなかったら良かったんだよと思うことなんですね
我々に生まれがこっち書いてますね
しかし これは欲求によって得ることができません
これが求めて得られない苦である
これは求めたっても得られないんですね
生まれてこなかったら良かったと思ったっても
思うこと自体バカバカらしいんですね
得られるわけじゃないんだから
そこで老いる法則のものである有情に次のような欲求が生じます
我々が老いる法則のものでなければ良いのに
我々に老いが来なければ良いのにと
年だけ取らなかったらというふうに思っちゃうんですね
年取るのは嫌だ嫌だとかね
思ったりする いくら思ってそんなことは欲求希望したっても得られるものではありませんと
そこで病気になる法則の我々が病気だけにはなりたくないんだと希望する
欲求する そんなものは希望
欲求で得られるものではありません
そこで死ぬ法則の生命だから
死にたくはないんだと
どうか死なないようにというふうに希望したりする
得られるものではありませんと
次にまた全部まとめて憂い
悲しみ 苦しみ 憂い 悩む法則に入っている人々が
また悲しいことを憂い
ことを悩むことはなければいいなと思ったりするでしょう
何の悲しみも苦しみもない人生があればいいなとかね
幸せいっぱいで生きていられればいいなとか思ったりする
でもそんなことを要求しているんだから
希望しているんだからって得られるものじゃないんだよ
法則だから 一応わかりやすい
この説明はそこら辺で終わりますけど
残るのは五取蘊の説明なんですけど
で 人間はこの欲求するでしょうに
人間の努力って何なのかというと
年取らないように努力する
病気にならないようにと努力する
それまた利己的やとも思っている
だから一向に一度も年取らなかった人はいません
病気にならなかった人はいません
死ななかった人はいません
でもいまだに頑張っている
それをまたものすごい利己的だと合理的だと思ったりもする
そういうわけだから 思想と仏教っていうのは全く正反対で
そんなものは人生だと
こんなしがみついて生きて生きて生きてきたいと思っているんですけど
結局あるのはそういうものですよと
それはもう固定して法則であって
法則だからどうしようもないでしょうに
法則は法則で理解しないんだから
雪が降ってくると寒いっていうのは法則でしょうに
火を触ったら火傷しますよと
そんなことは法則で それに悩む人がないでしょうに
世の中に我々には毎日朝も昼も両方ありますよと
日夜がありますよと そこで今光があって
太陽があって それ消えると太陽が見えなくなってくると暗いでしょうね
誰も別に驚かないでしょ
それ止まってもらおうと思わないでしょ
それは法則だからどうしようもないんです
放っておけばいいんです
だから法則ということさえもわかってない
太陽はいつかもう消えてしまうんだろう
だから別にどうってことない
そんなこと止まることできませんだから
日夜があって四季があったりして
いろいろ変化起きたりする
これ人間にはもう何もすることはできません
だからそういうことには法則と言うんです
手に負えないんです 法則だから放っておくんです
同じく自分に対しても
それは法則なんですよ
生まれたら死ぬと その間で生まれた瞬間から年取っていくと
病気にもなると 好きな人から離れなくちゃいけないし
嫌なものに出会わなくちゃいけないし
なのに希望する して努力する
だから学問はほとんど無駄な学問がいっぱいあるのはそういうわけで
仏教的に考えると こんな無駄な採算なくして自然まで破壊する必要ないんです
必要なものにしか研究学問しないならば必要でないものをやる必要はないんです
今やっているほとんど 90%必要でないもの
だから何か細胞の中に
遺伝の中にこのあの回数券が入ってるんだと
細胞は何回あの分離できるかと
この回数は決まってるんだと
それ終わったら死んじゃうんだと
その回数券決まってる DNA を取り除けば
いつでも細胞は分裂しながら永久的に生きているんだと思って
今その回数券の DNA
研究して どのようにそれをいじれればできるかという今研究しているみたいですね
よく頑張っているんです
とつとらないで永遠に生きるために
あのバカどもはそこでどれくらい屁理屈かというと
私はそんな最先端なDNAの研究とか何一つも知りませんだけど
あんな話テレビで聞いただけで
こいつらバカではないかと
なぜかというと 細胞分裂のこの回数
何回分裂するかという回数を決めているところは取ってしまえば分裂しっぱなしでしょう
そうするとがん細胞なんです
それも一応分かっているんです
だから人間はがん細胞の塊になればいいということでしょうね
生きていられないんですよ
例えば心臓細胞も分裂すると心臓はがんになるでしょうに
脳細胞を分裂しちゃうと脳ががんになるでしょうね
冗談じゃないんですよ
それでどうやって生きていられますかね
例えば体が大きくなってなってなってなっていくんだと
恐竜みたいに どこかでコントロールしなきゃ生命にならないんです
回数券決めないと 単純な論理なんです
子供の時のように 赤ちゃんの時のように
まあ分裂するだけで これありがたいやと思うこと自体おかしいでしょうね
大人が赤ちゃんの寿命
生命がありがたいと思うと
赤ちゃんそう思ってますかね
赤ちゃんにとってはそれは苦しみだから
幼稚園の子供たち可愛いと思うのは我々であって
その子供たちはそう思ってないでしょう
自分のことは その子供たちにも人生は大変なんです
不幸なことばっかりなんです
道路に歩いたっても 我々よりはものすごい強烈な排気ガスを吸わなくちゃいけないし
自分よりは何十倍も高い車やらトラックやら行くと
どれぐらい心が心臓がドキドキして怯えるかというと
それは全然想像もしない大人が可愛い可愛いと
私たちは背が高いんだから平気で道路を渡るんだけど
子供たちにとってはこれはかなりきついんですよ
たとえ白い線で車停まって車の方見たら
バカでかい車だから 私たちでもものすごいでかいもうもうスピード出る
もう来る車なんかの前通って渡ろうと思ったら絶対渡らないでしょうね
それだったら だからまあ大人がそう思うだけで
子供にとってはその生命
その時間でも大変なことなんです
赤ちゃんにしてみれば
服を着させるは着かせるは
暑くてたまらないんだけど
これ言えないでしょうに
そこで何か帽子かぶったり
足に何かそけておいたりする
子供はもうイライライライラしてそれを外したりするでしょ
そうすると蒸んでおくんです
子供にとっては暑くてたまらないのに
いっぱい服を着させて暖房もつけてあげる
ざまあみろ この乳母車に引っ張ってる子供のことを考えてください
いかに子供は苦しいかと
あの暑い空気の中でほこりだらけで
私たちから子供は何のことなく気持ちよく楽に座ってるんだと
冗談じゃないんですよ
子供の立場から考えちゃうと
それは体験したければ
そうやってすごい低い何かに乗り物に自分も座って行ってみれば？横になって
普通の道路で何かね おす車とかあるでしょうね
そういうものに横になって座って
あまり高くない乳母車ぐらいの 20センチ 10センチぐらいの高さのものに
なぜ横にやってもらうかと
この鼻の位置 目の位置
子供と同じようにならないと
どういうことかと 植物やらどのように見られるかと
歩いている人はどのように見られるかと
横に通っている自転車はどのように見られるかと
大人でも怯えると思いますよ
で 空気が呼吸ができなくて
我々はもう大人の好き勝手に考えているんだから
ですから この大人がそこでもう頭の非論理的と言うともう切りがないんですよ
僕らから言えば そういう気持ちで考えて
やっぱり子供の時はみんな可愛くて
細胞は元気で だからこの年取る原因だけ取っちゃえばいいんじゃないかなと思っちゃうんです
その年取る原因はDNAから取ってしまえば
すぐさちまち死んじゃう
癌だから 全体的に癌ですから
そうすると 何一つも信頼できない
例えば目の細胞なんかはね
もうどんどんどんどん成長して
どうなるんですかね 目は
夜寝て朝起きたら変な目なんですよ
もしかすると いっぱい細胞分裂するんだから
どうなることをかと だからこんなものはありえないことで
こんな変なことやっちゃったらすぐそこで全滅なんですね
だから苦しみを避けられないんですよ
もし科学者が成功してDNAの老化原因電子遺伝子を取り除いたとすると
それで終わり 滅亡 結局同じ苦しみなんです
みるみるうちの人々がみるみるうちに死んで死に倒れていっちゃいますよということになります
いじれません 法則を いじることはできない
いじって何かどうってことはないんだから
医学の世界でそうすると細胞いじってるでしょうに
じゃあ今の人は元気で健康で
古い昔の人間が病弱でみんな早死になったんですかね
どうってことないでしょうね
昔の人もご飯食べて自然に生きてて死んじゃったし
何も貢献してないんですよ
よくよく見ると だから私が言うことはいろいろ変化はさせてるんだけど
あの 進化はさせてないんだと
成長はないんだと ただの変化だけ
それなのに人間っていうのはよくも屁理屈で考えちゃうんですね
年は取りたくないとかね
弱くなりたくないと 早く死にたくはないんだとかね
あるいはもう本当は死にたくはないんだと
それでも死んじゃうとすごい悔しいんですよ
死ぬことは 悔しさもバカバカしいでしょうに
当たり前だから そういうところで
もっともう早々接するインチキ屋が来て
え？これ体が潰れただけですよと
魂はもう死にませんと
魂は年も取りませんと
と言って慰めてあげる
あれ慰めてあげるんじゃなくて
あれすっごい詐欺 もともと頭悪い人にはとてつもない頭の悪い世界に落としてやる
落としてやる で 本人も落とされたことは知らないで
騙されたことは知らないで自慢する
私たちは神を信じて生きている
すごい立派な道徳的な人間だと
というふうな世界ですから
もう非論理といえばもう切りがないんですよ
とにかくこの瞑想でもって
やっぱり人間がそうやってこのいろんな希望をする
すべての希望をまとめてみると
年取りたくないということの最終的な結論がそれなんです
私の希望は勉強をすることやとかね
いろんな希望を言うでしょ
ああいうのは一時的なインチキ
嘘であって ずっと追求して
もう元の原因に行ってみてくださいと
言うと病気になりたくない
年は取りたくないとかね
そういうところになってしまうんです
時々みんなこのくだらんことにチャレンジするでしょ
例えば世界一周を普通のボートで行きたいんだと
それさえできれば死んでも悔いはないんだと
でもそれ成功したら死なないでしょうね
あれが本当のことだったら
これさえできれば 私はもう死んでも悔いはないんだと言って
自分のすごい希望を出しちゃうんですよ
これこそ私の人生の唯一の希望でしたと
そこ そういうのもたまたま成功する人々はいますよ
ただ死ぬんですかね あの連中がそれで
死なないでしょうに それで世界で名前売れちゃって
人気者になって有名になって
コスコスと生きてるんですね
だからああいう考え方っていうのは薄っすういところなんです
唯一の希望は まあスポーツマンとして銀メダルを取ることだと
それやればもう一回だけでもいいんだから
死んでも悔いはないんだと言って取ったところで死なない
ですから 人間の希望っていうのは
お釈迦様はそれはもうあまり人間の理屈はそこはないんだから
きちんと見たらこちらで書いてる希望なんですね
あるのは なぜこの愛する人から別れるものは苦しいと言ったところで
この色声香味触法のことを言ったんですか？いわゆる音を見られるもの
味とか言ったんですかでと
それは人間が分かってないんで
私はこの人とは一緒になりたいんだと
この人と一緒になることができれば何でもするぞと言うでしょうね
あれは嘘であって 非論理であって
その人の形が気に入る目で
その人の観測が自分に体で気に入る
だいたいそれぐらい でも喋ってる言葉は気に入らない
だから一緒になってもそれで喧嘩になったりする
その人の味の好みは気に入らないとかあるでしょう
それで料理について色々問題ができたりする
そこを明確でないんだから
みんなもう大変なことになります
どうしてもこの人と一緒になりたいなと思ってなったっても
結局は不幸になるケースっていうのはいくらでもあります
ですから それぐらいでもはっきりしているんだったら
私はこの人の体形 目で見たらその美しさは好きですよと
ちょっと触ってみたら
あんまりそんなに感動しないんだったら
もうやめた方がいいんですね
マスコットとしてはいいんだけど
触ったりする場合はもういいということだから
一緒にならない方がいいでしょうに
そこで喋ってみたら声も綺麗だったら声も綺麗ですよ
でも喋った内容は綺麗じゃない場合はね
やっぱり声自体はいいんだけど
内容は頭には気に入らない
その場合は法ですからね
頭ですからね やっぱりこの人の ABC は好きなんですけど
DEF はいらないと やって数学的に考えれば一緒になるかなれるかということは計算できるでしょうね
例えば人と付き合うっていうこと
その人は 5つ持ってるでしょ
我-私がある人と付き合うということは
コミュニケーションを取るのはこの五感でしょうに
五感で相手のことを知ってます
それから六感目 あの意識で相手のことを考えたりする
だから六つでしょうに
そこで じゃあＡＢＣＤＥＦとあるんだと
まあＡはマルと ＢはもうＢもマルと Ｃ
は三角だと Ｄはバツだと Ｅ
もバツだと ったらこれわかるでしょうに
それだったら 一緒になれるなるべきがなら-どうかということ
そうは誰一人そうやって考えないでしょう？あ
この人はもう可愛い それでも飛び出す
飛び出す だから論理的にというならば
ちゃんと論理的になってほしい
こちらに人がいるっていうことは
目で見て耳で聞いてとか
そういう手段でしか知られ-知られませんだから
喋ったりすると二つですよ
音と内容 いくら気に入る
ものすごい柔らかい美しい綺麗な声で喋ったという内容はとんでもないものだったら
それで頭の中混乱するって気持ち悪くなるでしょうに
だからこの六つのチャネルを考えて
自分が単なる六つのチャネルのことしか考えてないんだと
そこはもう全部マルか
どれぐらいマルかと決めれば
ちゃんと論理的に決められるのに
それでも意味がない なぜならば変化するんだから
その六つのチャネルもマルであろうとも
色が変化しているでしょう
形が そうするとマルはどんどん三角になってバツになるでしょうに
声は立派だなと思ったっても
それはどんどん年取っていくでしょうに
まあ声のプロだったら体が年取っても声は衰えませんだけど
そうするとあまりにもうるさくなっちゃうんです
例えば歌手とかね そういう人々がもう八十歳になっても体がボロボロなんですけど
声だけはバカでかいんですよ
さらにアンバランスで
他の人々にとっては気に入らなくなっちゃうんです
その時も すごい声が 若い時はもの立派な声を持ってる人々と
ちょっと付き合ってみてください
仲良く友達みたいに まあ声は綺麗だけど
普通の日常生活する中
でもあの声だから我慢できないんですよ
いつでもバカでかい響く声で喋ると
それもそんなに忍耐できるわけじゃないんです
その声で何か歌ったりするといいかもしれません
そっちを歌っちゃうと
ちょっと冗談じゃないんです
ですから この結局そうやって
あの可愛いと思って目ででしょう？その対象が老いていくんだから
もうやっぱり丸であってもどんどん三角になってバツになっちゃう
そういうことですからね
逆に自分の感覚器官が衰えてしまったらどうしますかと
相手がすごい若くて元気で綺麗なんですけど
自分がもう病気になって倒れちゃってボロボロになったりすると
それまた苦しいでしょうに
まあそういう風な世界ですね
人生っていうのは だからこの
この我々の思考をやめて
物事を直視する 考えないで
そのまま見てみると 何の苦しいこともなく
真理だけで止まっちゃうんですね
普通 勉強するためにすごい苦しいでしょうね
もういとも簡単にはそういうことかと理解できるしね
で  次に五取蘊の話に行きます
で 三決定のまとめて言えば五取蘊は苦しみであると
それはヴィパッサナー瞑想する人にしかわからないことなんですね
だからあの地震が起きてね
親戚はみんな死んじゃいましたよと
これぞいった苦しみよと
憂いですよと 悲しみですよというのは普通なんですが
ヴィパッサナーで来れて自分がいるんだからでしょ
自分という個々がいるんだから
そういう問題が起きたんであって
原因は自分なんです 自分の全部親戚が死んだ
自分が悲しい 誰のせいだ
自分のせいでしょうに
自分がいるんだから 自分に親戚がいるんであって
自分にそういう人々と接することできたんだから
自分が気に入っていたでしょうね
見たり聞いたり喋ったり
親が作ってくれるご飯を食べたり
それを楽しがったり 自分の自分が自分の体を喜ばせていたでしょうに
それがなくなったんだから苦しみがあるでしょ
だから体でしょうね 結局は自分のせいなんですね
だから原因は自分だよと
苦しみの原因は ということをわかるんです
自分に目があるんだから
目で変なものを見て苦しくなっちゃうし
耳があるんだから耳で変なことを聞いて苦しくなっちゃうし
結局は苦しみを作ってくれたのは母親ではなくて
別れた相手ではなくて
自分なんです 自分の体なんです
そこで瞑想するとよくわかるでしょうね
別に誰かが来ていじめてるわけじゃないでしょうに
誰かが来て悩ませてるわけじゃないでしょうに
いろんな悩みやら頭の中でいろんな妄想やら出てくるで
誰かがやらせてるんですか？あんなもの自分勝手にやってるだけだから
いくら論理的な話したって
一向に理解しないとするのは私ですか？自分
自分たちですかね だから問題は実質的に自分にあるということなんですね
理解すれば悟れるのに
悟れないでまた瞑想して頑張ってみる
それまた苦しいし それも
瞑想するんだけど悟れないと
それ私に当たっても私は知らないよ
そんなことは だから一向に論理的にならないのも自分でしょうに
一向に事実をありのままに認めたくないっていうのは
それまた自分でしょうに
限りなく余計なことを妄想して妄想して
自分の欲望でいろんなイメージを作ったりして
そこらに閉じ込められたい
幻覚の中で閉じ込められているのは
それまた自分でしょうに
ですから 引いて考えれば
苦しみっていうのは自分の体なんです
だから五取蘊にしているんですね
五取蘊っていうのは五つでしょ
色 物体的な体 それにもとらわれてますね
可愛いと この体は大事やと
だから苦しいんです ただの機械ということになったら
どうったことない 壊れようか
故障しようが どうせ機械だから期限がありますから
なぜ食べ物にだけ賞味期限があって
他のものにないんですかね
全てのものにあるでしょうに
桜の木にしたっても 永遠に花が咲いてくれるわけじゃないでしょうに
せいぜい立派に花が咲くのは年ぐらいでしょうに
たまたま環境が良くて
栄養が良くて 三十年の年の桜も年のものもありますけどね
でも一般的にはもう枝が折れたり色々あって
もう死んじゃうんでしょうに
だから期限があります
なんで自分の体にだけ期限があると思わないんですか？それ屁理屈じゃないんですか？全てのものに期限がありますから
締め切りがありますから
それは他人にはあるんだけど
私にはないっていうことですから
これはあまりにも屁理屈なんですね
でも他人から見れば 自分にもちゃんと締め切り期限があるでしょうに
でも自分がそう思わないだけ
それはね あの仏教の違う例えで言えば
この一人の人が自分の考え方だけ正しいと
他の人々の考え方は全く間違っていると徹底的に壊す
それで潰れる 他人の考え方
そこで次の人も自分の考え方だけ正しいと
他の人々の考え方間違っているで全部潰れると
そうやってみんな私は正しい
他人がみんな間違っているというと
誰が正しいんですかね
どう計算したって 例えば人いるとする
一人が自分が正しいと人が間違っているというでしょ
そうすると自分の意見に投票してみたところで
賛成一票 反対でしょ 反対ですね
誰の意見を取ったってそういうことなんです
だから人に否定されてますね
だから結局みんな同じなんです
そうすると誰も正しくないんです
それは論理に対してお釈迦様の考え方なんですけど
普通の人間の感覚だと同じことで
我々食べるものには賞味期限がある
使うものには賞味期限がある
賞味 一応期限がある 使うものにも期限があって
食べるものにも賞味期限があるんだったら
その体にも同じくあるでしょうに
でも体が可愛いんだから
これは別扱い あの別視するところは何なのかと
そこで理屈はなくなっちゃうでしょ
そこを直してほしい だから体は壊れる機械やと思っちゃえば
もう執着捨てればそこで問題はなくなる
一番目は体のこと 色 色蘊
色の番目に来るのは受ですね
受 感じること 体で 目で
耳で いろんなところでもう感じるんですね
外の世界 それで私がいるんだというすごい誤解もしたりする
ただの感じることだからどうしたことないんですよ
ただ音を感じる 光を感じる
体でいろんなことを感じる
耳で感じる 鼻で感じる
舌で感じる 頭でも感じる
それだけ見たら誰でもない
犬も猫も猿もみんな同じことをやってますから
ウジ虫も同じことやってるでしょうに
周りをちゃんと感じてるでしょうに
それだけのこと そこで故に我
私がいると あれがヘリクツなんです
ですから 感じることもずっと変化しているでしょうに
いつでも同じものを感じたって生きていられませんだから
お茶飲んだら感じが違うし
ご飯食べたら感じが違うし
同じ感じだったらもう
そうさせてください ご飯食べても同じ味で
お茶飲んでも同じ味で
おかず食べても同じ味で
もうヨーグルトですら同じ味だと
水飲んだって同じ味やと
どうなるんですかそうすると
それだったら魂があると思ったってもいいんです
そうじゃないでしょうに
触れるたびに感じが違う
そんな音を聞こえないでしょうに
同じ音だ 感じが同じだったら
たった一つの音になってしまっちゃうんで
そうすると だから瞬間瞬間変化するんだから
我々は音を感じるっていうこと
だからこの感覚っていうのはね
そんなどうったことない
すぐすぐすぐ瞬間瞬間変化していくんだということ
でもそれは自分が別だと
自分だと ありがたいだと思っちゃう
そこら辺は何の論理もない
だからそのまま見れば
ただそれだけの真理なんです
ありのまま見れば で これはジュー
ウェイだな サンニャーっていうのはこの概念
いわゆる妄想の世界ですね
いろんな出来事を考えたりする
晩ご飯どうしますかとかね
そうやって概念の塊がサンニャーであって
サンカーラっていうのは
やっぱりこの まあ行動的にやりたい
やりたい やりたいと出てくるエネルギーでしょうに
それも簡単にわかるでしょうに
いつでも何かやりたいという気持ちでいるんだから
呼吸もしたい 見たい 聞きたい
喋りたい 考えたい 寝たい
起きたい 歩みたいという何かしたい
それは一向にもう止まらないんです
ずっと だからただ単に何かしたいだけ
ウジ虫も人間も同じ それで自分が何かしたいんだから偉いと
自分だけ 私はこういうことをしたいんですよと
こういう希望でいるんだよとか威張ったりする
そんな不思議な大したことじゃないんで
ただ単にみんなやってるんだから
やりたいこと 音楽であろうが
科学研究であろうが 原子爆弾を作ることであろうが
もうどうったことない
ただ何かやりたいということだけから発生するんですよ
それに他の妄想がいろいろ絡み合うことで変化するだけで
やりたいという気持ちも永久的じゃないですよ
すぐ変わる それはサンカーラなんですね 5
番目はヴィンニャーナ
それは心ですね 知る機能
目で感じるだけではなくて
目を通して知る 耳を通して知るということで
まあそれもみんな同じことを知るだけなんですからね
だから別にどうったことない
だからそこから苦しみが
それ自体が苦しみですよ
その五取蘊自体が ということでドゥッカの真理は終わるんですね
だから瞑想していくと
大体それはまあよくわかるんですよ
何も考えないで単純に瞑想すればすぐわかるんです
よくよく深く深く考えて瞑想すると
40年ぐらいかかるかもしれません
何も考えないで見てれば
ああ こういったかなりきついもんだと
座ることもきついし 歩くこともきついし
呼吸自体もきついし もういろいろ希望が生まれてくるし
それまたきついんだよと
納得いかないでしょうと
うまく瞑想できると思ったところでうまくいかないし
瞑想できるなと思ったところで
何か訳があって瞑想できなくなったりするし
そうやって希望がダメになっちゃうでしょうに
そうすると気持ち悪くなるでしょうね
せっかく瞑想しようといったところで風邪引いて
なかなかもう瞑想するところじゃなくなっちゃうでしょ
悔しいでしょうね それ希望を失ったことだから
ただ単純に見れば もうドッカというのはもうもう分かりきってるはずなんですけど
ヴィパッサナーで観察しちゃうと
きりがなく苦しみだけ延々と一つの苦しみ消えて
次の苦しみが現れる それだけではないかと
そこで瞑想する人々というのは幻覚に隠れる場合もあるでしょ
幻覚に隠れたら気持ちいいとかね
でもどこかで苦しみはやってくるんです
それでも 幻覚に隠れちゃうと
この神秘的な経験とかなんとかとか
へんてこりんな嘘ばっかしって
神秘体験なんかね まぁとんでもないへんてこりんなことですからね
人間の理屈だから 真理でしょ？体験してほしいのは
なんで一人の人にだけ特別な神秘体験があって
その他大勢の人間にはないと
なぜその一人の人の経験だけ真理であって
全ての人の経験が間違っていると言える？どんな論理でいるんですかね
この神秘体験というのも
もう全て仏教ではね 幻覚なんです
光見えるなりに 声は聞こえるなりに
色々ありますけど どんどんもう
いろんなもの見えるとかね
幻覚として見ているんだけどね
アビダンマでははっきりと幻覚だと
パンニャーティだと言ってるんだからね
で それだけ正しくて 他の正しくないと
それで他の人もその幻覚を体験しようと思ったり
また頑張ったりする だからまあそれだけ幻覚に隠れたって
もう苦しみはどんどん覆ってくる
そういうことだから 単純にこの観察してみると
まあすぐわかるのは まあそういうドッカであるということなんですね
ドッカっていうのは まあやりきれないっていう
まあいくらやっても まあこんなもんでしょうと
この中でこれしかもう何もないでしょうという諦め
この何か深い意義を探すことを諦めるんです
とてつもない真理を探してみようではないかと
諦めてみれば それこそとてつもない真理なんです
この諦め 諦めないこと自体がヘリックスなんです
じゃあ一応ドッカしか今日はできませんので
そこら辺で終了します
[背景音楽]